[Music]
david bodd made a new video
did he yeah dude it's pretty cool so
this is david bond's video all right uh
david bond the person who has a
fake korean lawyer um
shall we check out his video is he fun
is he
the 13 year old girl from it's always
sunny with a north korean girl
that's exactly who this looks oh the one
charlie dated yes yeah
yeah yeah you know you don't want to
kiss you know it's all sticky from the
candy and the beer
all right david bond let's see what you
got
title of the video the four the top four
life lessons
what i've learned from traveling for
five years before you hit play i just
want to reiterate for any fake
made up korean attorneys out there that
might potentially want to
fake sue me in a fake court uh that i'm
not saying that she's underage i don't
want i want to establish that
but she looks so underage that doesn't
shouldn't that
like that you should be weird for
wanting to [ __ ] a chick that looks she
looks like a wood elf
[Laughter]
oh my god specifically hey what no
you're right what else
if you're going for an archer build
something with stealth
and you're tired of doing dark elf yeah
what
very low constitution that's the problem
[Music]
see all his videos are him showing off
his babes
he's babes i hate you i hate that you
you don't like his
word and you know a lot of people are
going to look at this right
and um they look at this and they go man
dude they must be loaded i mean look
where he's staying at i've looked up
these places in like
bali and stuff like that and i'm not
even kidding you look up yourself these
places are 60 bucks a night
american this place in la would be like
ten thousand dollars of course but in
bali it's like 60 bucks a night
is david bond in this video or is he
just showing off his hot chicks
i want to go here now i mean forget not
for the underage looking
just for the place
don't look at me i don't know what this
what is it i don't listen
teach me one two three four five no
no song i guess sure wears a lot of
american hats for someone who hasn't
been here in 30 years
he's wearing clothes from the joey
gibson collection seriously
sam sam c
it looks like dude this is like he
he's literally it's like he's talking to
a toddler right
why is he wearing a shirt in the pool
that's actually a very good point
that's a very good point tip
gib yes gab bad bad yes
what does this have to do with things
he's learned he's four life lessons but
doesn't this feel like when somebody's
got like their toddler sitting on their
lap
and a toddler's just imitating them
is he gonna talk or
[Music]
all all [ __ ] aside
i got to say that face though
all [ __ ] aside it's a really nice
view
super nice beautiful that would be
absolutely beautiful i want
everything in this video minus these
[ __ ] underage looking [ __ ]
like i would be fine you just be like
can you get me this set up and since
we're in a foreign country can you get
me some kind of like
really good street drugs like i'm
thinking
i'm thinking the heroine here has
probably got to be some of the best in
the world can you get probably
heroin and also get me this view and i'm
fine i don't need the hose
they all look so comfortable this this
one that he's really clinging to she
seems very comfortable
okay remember this video is four lessons
i've learned by traveling for five years
i've skipped to five minutes in
five minutes learning lessons
[Music]
like what is this video about if
look if we got like super rich right
doing this show
and then you came like you came to hang
out one day
and i was just sitting here with these
very uncomfortable tents
these these two what appear to be
underage asian girls that are shivering
like chihuahuas
and i'm like royce what's going on and
then they're like awkwardly kissing each
other
like wouldn't you take me aside and go
hey man like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you like are
you okay like do you
what is wrong what are you what are you
becoming what's happening to you
this isn't normal this is how normal
people are
i would i'm six minutes in i don't know
the life lessons yet
i wanna i know i want to live a badass
lifestyle like this
what happened
[Music]
so mark what do you think
this guy's like yeah hey um can you
please not show me on tape
thanks please don't show me on video man
i still have some bubbles so as you guys
know i recently turned
35 years old and five years
is also the amount of time that i have
successfully lived
independently without a job it's been
five years
since i quit my last job at the carrot
factory in bakersfield
and i think five years is enough time to
give you guys
a few life lessons these are things
david are you vlogging
should i not interrupt you right now are
you vlogging
no
just let it go here's why
when you travel the world when you go to
new countries
you are going to be at a very massive
disadvantage often you're going to be in
a place that you don't speak the
language
no you're not you i mean i mean you are
but you don't have to put yourself in
that position you may be visiting a
country where you don't speak the
language
you don't know your rights look either
grow a beard or don't but there's no
mustache thing
always bothers me and also what's what's
with the whole like he's making it sound
like bro it's such a huge challenge to
go to a country where you don't speak
their language yeah i know
but also one of your dollars is worth
like 10 000 of their dollars
so can you also stop pretending like
you're at this
massive disadvantage because i know
america oh
i don't speak the language i don't know
the cultures you know you have american
dollars don't you so calm down
you'll be invited to a system of
positive
emotions the reason you're in this
[ __ ] this
strange place where everyone speaks a
weird language is because you can't get
your dick sucked in la
david you're not a guy
that could just easily get your dick
sucked in los angeles
you're not a guy that can afford to stay
as roy said earlier
at a place that looks like that but in
los angeles
and frankly if you could afford a place
like that in los angeles
you probably still wouldn't get your
dick sucked
that girl would probably still want to
go to the comedy store and blow paulie
shore
because she saw encino man once like you
don't
you don't have the juice brother to pull
[ __ ] in la
and that's coming from a guy who does
not have the juice
to pull [ __ ] in l.a so i'm not trying
to say like i'm cool and you're not
but i'm not flying to vietnam to try to
pay
to whatever does it matter what you're
saying
is not something that you should take
for granted
it's like i said cambodia and royce is
like it's actually laos
that you share the same values with that
is not as easy
over the past few years share the same
values with do you really have something
in common with these women sir
i've made a lot of really cool friends
and one thing and then i doxed a bunch
that's good that was a good one my great
friends
that i'd [ __ ] dox their phone numbers
on my youtube page
a.g clipped that and he and because aj
is a good guy
a.g actually blurred out the clip that
we he blurred out the thing he was like
well i'm not gonna post her [ __ ]
yeah no and that's the right way to do
it i
quickly realized it's not hard to make
friends
when you have way more when your money
is valued way more than theirs
when you come from an empire that uh
pretty much runs the world
yeah it's like having those roman coins
but being in some shitty
[ __ ] celtic mud hut village
they're like oh shiny roman coins
friends that are in the same position
you are
now all of us are in different stages of
life all of us
are at different levels it's not hard
to meet some weird european backpacker
at a hostel it is hard
to meet a location independent smart
guy like yourself who has the same he's
smart values and is in the same position
you need to understand that as a man
there is
a part of you that has millions of years
of evolution right your mind as a human
is the product of millions of years of
evolution and you know what most of your
ancestors did
to survive i don't know guy who got high
and listen to joe rogan tell me
yeah they hunted human beings
are hunter gatherers we would live in
small 1
to 200 person hunter-gatherer
tribes most of us lived in small
villages one to two hundred people
what did men in those societies do to
survive
they went to thailand with a bunch of
money and paid people
i'm not saying you did that i'm just
historically saying that's what they did
yeah my ancestors were hunter gatherers
they would go out
uh in groups and they would strap gopros
to their heads and then dangle bitcoin
cash
to uh in front of thai prostitutes some
of which were possibly men
my it's funny because my ancestors were
cubans so they would go to cuba and buy
them a fubu shirt
and then they would sleep with them for
a fubu
shirt yeah no it's really in style over
there it still is it just got fubu
no that's i meant i if you're over there
that's what i'd be saying to the girl no
it's really hot over in the states
people love it you like fila
i have fela oh [ __ ]
they went out and hunted they went out
in small groups
of three to six no my ancestors were not
and they went out into the
dangerous wild and killed things
are you kidding me they brought them
back to the rest hope he's not i hope
you're not killing these please tell me
you're not killing hookers bro i'm not
saying you are but i hope you're not
the tribe if you read
human evolution books if you read books
on the history
of the human race oh i'm sorry do you
not
read human evolution books can you give
me a specific one david
can you show me your human evolution
category
yeah it's just darwin that's like the
only it's just one copy of darwin's
[ __ ] origin of the species and that's
it there's no other books
it's just it's one book it's origin of
the species by darwin
and then a bunch of other books where
they point at origin of the species by
darwin and go
see right you're right
societies have scientific
style where small groups of
men would go out and hunt
and then as a man there's a part of your
brain
that seeks that male bonding
aspect for david hundreds of thousands
of years
your ancestors went into environments
that were scary
and unknown and they david like a thai
massage parlor for example
david there were no hunter gatherers in
my uh ancestors
and can i be honest with you uh i'll
give you a little background because you
keep talking about how
how resilient and tough my ancestors
were
i come from a group of people that only
learned how to grow one plant
and then when we when that plant stopped
and the soil dried up
we literally just went well i give up
i am i'm out of ideas like that's when
you understand i come from a group of
people that
abandoned to their country in mass
because we couldn't make potatoes
anymore
and people went why don't you fish
everybody's like ah sounds like a whole
thing
just go to the us and get a shitty
factory job and beat my wife
that's pretty much what happened yeah my
my people because i'm cuban so my people
come from spain so basically what they
did was
they went over to cuba and they go like
man these people are really stupid let's
just kill them all and just take over
and then we did pretty pretty dope and
then there's cuba
conquered things together they achieved
something together
they went in with a similar vision they
were staring
in you know through the forest or
through the jungle and hunting animals
killing them and that is in
your dna there's a part of you
that craves male bonding there's a part
of you that craves are you [ __ ] the
same
[ __ ] toots are you [ __ ] something he
wants to [ __ ] dudes is that why he was
like hey are you vlogging because he was
like
do you want to get in there and start
working on that thing for you
it's funny though but when this video
ends and the girls are just playing
playstation in the living room and they
both go upstairs to vlog together yeah
just vlogging you guys hey guys leave us
alone we're gonna go vlog upstairs
i've seen catfish i know what's going on
our vlogging gets really loud
i know we're very loud vloggers i know
what's going on with youtube production
partners i know that all
that old only one bet remember man
that's early days that's like fifth
circle stuff
the the two catfish guys only one bed
was ever
i was ever like used and the other one
was always bothered me yeah